three of her cast mates are now looking
for work in a surprising SNL shake-up
not returning this fall after six
seasons each on the show our Taran
Killam and Jay Ferrel that's what Jay
killed it is Barack Obama and check out
his Eddie Murphy clearly I don't hate
immigrants Terran had trumped down and
Matt McConaughey hola Kemosabe Terran
who is married to Cobie Smulders and
once guessed it on How I Met Your Mother
said that he was never given a reason
why he was leaving but he took it in
stride tweeting Lorne was kind enough to
understand I needed more time to
dedicate to my undefeated Rams
that would be exec producer Lorne
Michaels who also let Jon rudnitsky go
after one season SNL's kyle mooney
reminded us that Lorne is often changing
up the cast you kind of never know
what's gonna happen
Oh Lauren keeping you in the dark by the
way I just want to remind everybody al
holds the record for the most Emmy
nominations and wins of any show out
there they're nominated for 17 more next
month of Kate McKinnon the only cast
member who got a nomination very well
deserved to love her